well today for our daily cancellation uh
I will tell you that I very nearly had
to cancel my wife again she is I think
like a six-time returning champion of
the daily cancellation segment and uh
she almost earned a seventh for her
latest
infraction now as viewers of the video
podcast uh can see I am once again today
in my home office after the mega winter
Vortex snow apocalypse dropped like 5
Ines of snow in Nashville and shut down
all the roads for the next 17 days at
least um and nobody plows and nobody
treats the roads around here because
they always say that well we don't have
to plow and tree because we never get
snow and I've been hearing that every
every winter for the last four years
that I've been here and every winter
we've gotten snow so I'm starting to
think that we get snow maybe you should
learn how to treat the anyway so we're
stuck here uh none of that is my wife's
fault that's not what I'm blaming for
what is her fault is that she apparently
put a um well we were just talking about
pets and she apparent if you know if you
can see this but this is a framed
picture of the cat um it's not my cat
this is my daughter's cat uh this this
this is her pet just to be clear but
this is the frame picture it's a nice
frame it's not on the bookshelf anymore
she apparently put that on the bookshelf
behind me right in the shot yesterday
and I didn't notice it until after I'd
finished recording the show so any
eagle-eyed viewer on Monday could have
watch the show and mistakenly come to
the conclusion that I'm the sort of man
who keeps a framed picture of the cat on
his bookshelf um I think the glare from
the light might have saved me so I'm not
even sure how visible so I might just be
outing myself for this in a way that I
didn't need to um but if someone had
seen that they might have come to the
conclusion that I liveed some sort of
double life like publicly pretending to
be relatively normal while privately I'm
some sort of cat obsessed freak and and
her plot is made all the more Sinister
by the fact that as she well knows you
know I pay absolutely no attention to
any of the decor in any room that I'm
sitting in I mean she could have removed
the bookshelves behind me entirely and
replaced them with like a 900 lb giant
cat sculpture and I probably would not
have noticed like it would have taken me
a few minutes at least it's only by the
grace of God that I I caught the cat
picture um though I did I did so a day
late um and all that said as devast ated
as I
am and as worried as I am about getting
the
reputation um an unfair reputation as a
cat person I have to admit it's a pretty
decent prank you know it I mean it's it
will require some retaliation uh you
know but but uh of course but I respect
it all the same and for that reason I'm
not going to cancel her today also
because another group of much much much
more worthy candidates have revealed
themselves and um when I say reveal
themselves I I mean it literally they
have in fact revealed far too much of
themselves a few days ago Valley Metro
the public Transit Agency in Phoenix
played willing host to something called
No Pants Light Rail day now as the name
would seem to indicate no pants Light
Rail day is a day when people ride the
light rail in Phoenix without any pants
um the Phoenix New Times advertised the
event last week you could see a
screenshot of their article which I want
you to see so that you can make note of
the very clear LGBT branding that
they're giving this thing because of
course they are because of course if
there's an event where uh you know uh
people are running around without their
clothes on in public you automatically
know that there's some LGBT attachment
to this thing and uh sure enough there
it is so here's what the article says
after a four-year wait Valley residents
have an excuse to take their pants off
in public again Phoenix's no pants Light
Rail ride return turns this weekend for
the first time since 2020 as the name of
the event implies it involves locals
hopping aboard Valley Metro Rail without
any pants skirts or shorts participants
are dressed in underwear tops and shoes
though the infamous event equal uh equal
part flash mob and urban prank is
scheduled for Sunday it's one of
Phoenix's unique and cheeky events
earning its underwear clad participants
stares glares and smiles from onlookers
or fellow Light Rail passengers during
its original run it was also quite
popular Phoenix's no pants Light Rail
ride dates back to 2009
um and then there were spin-offs in
other cities and they stopped doing it
during the
pandemic
um so that was at least one positive
from that whole experience and now
they're back to it so and this is
something that apparently happens in
cities across the country Baltimore had
its own uh pantless public transit Day
on Sunday so if you were already
concerned that the seats on public
transportation were covered in a thick
coating of the most putrid and
potentially infectious germs imaginable
well this should pretty much confirm
those suspicions um but it's all just a
prank we're told it's a it's a prank a
silly prank you know indecent exposure
is okay as long as it's done under the
guise of a prank we're supposed to
believe but if you look at the images
from this event which apologies ahead of
time um I'm about to force you to do you
will see that this does not appear to be
a band of marry pranksters but rather a
group of exhibitionists and
fetishists um as you might expect
so here's just to demonstrate that
here's some footage taken by local media
uh viewer discretion very much advised
here it
[Music]
is
now the good news is that if you were
too busy uh today to to to eat lunch um
well then I guess I've done you a favor
because now you don't have an appetite
for it anyway but as you could see there
were people in in in uh you know there
were people taking part in this who were
in furry costumes people in fetish gear
people that are clearly not as a prank
but because they enjoy exposing
themselves in public exposing themselves
to who well I can tell you you that
there were children in attendance um and
when I say in attendance at the very
least they were on public transportation
that day presumably with their parents
whether their parents brought them for
this event I don't know but there were
children there as you can see here um at
least two young children were on the
light rail car standing next to a guy
with no pants wearing high heels and
leather underwear with the word fetish
written on the front and this was
allowed to happen out in the open on
public
Transportation while the City of Phoenix
to my knowledge has never said a word
against it or made any attempt to stop
people from taking off their pants in
front of toddlers on the light light
rail it's not like they didn't know it
was happening it's like it's announced
and advertised ahead of
time they they you know you could speak
up and say uh no do not do you're not
allowed to ride public transportation
without pants on you could have said
that and they didn't now needless to say
in a sane country all of the adults
involved would be in jail for at a
minimum indecent exposure um but just as
needless to say we we don't live in a
sanee country so none of these adults
will face any consequences for this
disgusting degeneracy at all and perhaps
worst of all even if they will not
experience any legal penalty as they
should um they also will not feel shame
and and that is the big takeaway from
really everything that happens in our
culture these days but especially from a
nationwide event that involves
fetishists riding public transportation
in their underwear
um not to be mistaken with like cracked
out homeless people that ride in their
underwear every day for other reasons or
maybe for the same reasons I don't know
but the big takeaway is that this can
only happen and and will inevitably
happen in a culture without shame and
we've worked very hard to remove shame
from our society we have declared that
um shaming you know is a universal evil
it's the worst thing you can do is to
shame someone we've decided Ed that
being unashamed is a universal good and
all of that is very wrong because shame
serves a critical role for human beings
it's it's not it's not very dissimilar
from the role of the pain receptors in
your brain without the ability to feel
pain you know you you'd be able to keep
your hand on a hot stove without knowing
that you're burning yourself and this
will be very bad because although you
don't feel any pain from the burn you
are still being burned your body is
being damaged the pain is meant to alert
you to that fact so that you can protect
yourself pain is unpleasant to feel but
the alternative is much worse it's also
you know it's just like it's unpleasant
to hear smoke detectors blaring you know
nobody wants to hear that but it's even
worse and even more unpleasant to not
know that the fire has started in your
kitchen until it's too late so shame is
the same idea you know it is the the
unpleasant feeling you get when you have
behaved in a way that is disgraceful and
embarrassing and gross and otherwise Lo
some if you don't have the capacity to
feel shame or if you have trained
yourself to ignore the feelings when
they come then um you know you may be
spared the immediate unpleasantness of
the shameful feelings but you will be
doomed to disgrace and to debase
yourself repeatedly until you have you
have obliterated every semblance of your
own dignity and
self-respect you know you may not feel
the burn but you are disfigured by it
all the same only it's even worse in
this case because your disfigurement
also contributes to the disfigurement of
society your shamelessness is like a
disease it
spreads and we're all dragged into it
and before you know it you're standing
pantless on the subway while the rest of
us recoil in horror an eventuality that
that could have been avoided if you had
been shamed in the past and made to feel
that
shame but shame itself has been shamed
out of society and now we have a whole
lot of shameful Behavior without any of
the shameful feelings that should go
with
it so then it is up to me to say to the
pantless writers and Phoenix and
everywhere else in the country uh you
are all cancelled if You' like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wall Show
Twitter page hope to see you there God
speed